再说一个你们很多人做不成事的原因
你们总是七七万语我找到一个合适的想法我当来这么一个机会
我搞把当时的
但是我告诉你们你不可能
真有那么一个事
你根本就不会是像我这种的对手
为什么
因为我每天都在干事
气强
我每天都在气强
你以为当事来了以后你大干多少天我告诉你
真开始干的时候
我击乎不用劝
我劝那个强就是值得
而且非常的稳固
非常的勞靠
你去干那个事
你为发现你干的那个强
动到期外
速度还慢
质量还差
为什么
因为我这工作是每天踢出来的
你还得限续
咱俩根本就不在一个气跑线上
所以好多人说等我找到机会了我就怎么不行
等有机会了你白给
机会不可能水你等不来机会
风来的时候
我站在风口上等着
浪来的时候我就在水里
没道理我在水里的人敢不上那个浪
你在那岸边的人你敢上浪不可能
所以总是很有人说抱怨啊你就是干什么的好时代
我告诉你赶上好时代有两个事
就是每天我都在为这个风口做准备
我一直在那个地方等着风口
我赶上了自媒体时代
但是兄弟我说去扎心的话
你就算你知道这是自媒体红力
我给你一个时间机器
让你回到
2019年
到2020年
你和我一块做
你信不信
做成事那个人很可能还是我
不是你
我这么说话你可能不服
但是我跟你说个事你就明白了
在我做短视频之前
我已经写了十年的文章了
我已经做了十年的演讲了
你写一篇文案
需要三小时
我写一篇文案需要三分钟
你拍一条视频需要三小时
我拍一条视频需要三分钟
我拍短视频不需要心理购界
你拍一条短视频
你再战胜你自己
你再胜你自己跟翻译做删没啥区别呀
你会想什么我们领导看见怎么办
我爸妈看见怎么办
我家亲戚看得怎么办
我前女友看见怎么办
我的天呀你你战胜这个事你都后悔的很多能量
我不需要后悔的
我打开这种派我打开的时候我就是扶满的
你打开的时候你的经济已经后悔了一班了
我一张随就能说
你一张随就说错证了你就记不住词
一号不一背下了背两句忘了
你再停一段一段一段的企业
我三个中拍完了花一家投一区
生成个这么八争出去的你不行啊
你得一点一点拼铁呀你拼铁这个视频带一个多少时啊
这还是好的情况啊
所以我说了哪怕就算你知道这是个风楼让你回到二人一用年回到二人二年你信不信你还过不成
我明确告诉你
我每天都在做
我每天在做一件小事
我每天我哪怕写五十个字我都在写
你是看不起的五十个字的
你老想等着等机会来的时候我去呢
机会来了
跟你有个某很写